talk about the turn or the logic and
explain why it is useful
I forget who may not move it up shortly
it's like it's like fuzzy logic uh it's
meant to contrast with so if you like
it's kind of blinding okay when you
don't have black and white you've got
different shades in between you just not
sure so watch it you know this is what
we referred to by okay if you know BMI
is less is greater than now this is
logic there's a water it's well defined
above it you do something below it you
do something else
fuzzy logic is the officer right it's
that number one you might have these
numbers right but they got more of a
brain spectrum right I supposed to
you're on this side offense or that one
and not only that we have what we call
confidence
what's a confidence variable it has to
do with the database of facts there's
stuff that you know about a situation
okay but specifically it's how confident
are you that you know that to be true
because if your life decisions you have
to make where you're not a hundred
percent sure of all the details you
think you know but how certain you are
actually changing the decision that we
make okay so for instance I remember I
had a really bad experience one with a
weather report I read it it said it
would be like this and although okay
great I'm gonna wear all of this fast
off and it was a disaster I was like
wearing long sleeves I was burned to
death and so Mike Hoffman is very good
for looking at weather of words okay
particularly few days in advance they
plummeted okay so sometimes when you
hear things from different sources you
try just tree as true right now this is
a crucial problem that computer as
opposed to humans we just naturally this
all the time right so I'll take your
word on but but I'm not necessarily
gonna tree is 100% true and I feel may
be a decision support system that for
instance I said deal with conflicting
perspectives right then you're gonna
have to use these kinds of things to
factor it so fuzzy logic right it's
going to bring out different kinds of
decisions that are certain uncertain